[Música]
mañana los candidatos a la presidencia
de Brasil se encontrarán para un debate
de Cara a la segunda vuelta del 30 de
octubre y por ello traemos una serie de
informes especiales sobre el contexto en
el cual se celebrarán los comicios
en disturbios derivó una nueva jornada
de protestas en túnez miles de
opositores al gobierno salieron a las
calles pidiendo la salida del presidente
caixa Jet a quien acusan de concentrar
El Poder y de ser el culpable de la
crisis económica que atraviesa el país
en Rusia al menos 11 muertos dejó un
tiroteo en un campo de entrenamiento
militar según el Ministerio de defensa
ruso dos hombres armados pertenecientes
A una ex República soviética dispararon
contra soldados voluntarios Tenemos
reporte
Hola bienvenidos una nueva misión de
noticias en Francia 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Brasil mañana
los dos candidatos a la presidencia se
verán cara a cara antes de la segunda
vuelta del domingo 30 de octubre como
parte de nuestra serie de informes
especiales vamos a Río de Janeiro los
ciudadanos de las favelas y barrios más
pobres de la ciudad Se decanta
mayoritariamente por el izquierdista
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva para el
balotaje todo a pesar de que Río de
Janeiro es el estado bastión del
bolsonarismo a continuación los detalles
aquí en rosiña la Favela más grande de
Río de Janeiro la mayoría ya han hecho
su apuesta para la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones el ex presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva
bolso no hizo nada por mí al contrario
hizo las cosas más difíciles para las
personas de menores ingresos no mejoro
las cosas Aunque la gente diga que Lula
es un ladrón en los tiempos de Lula
podíamos comprar un televisor
en la primera vuelta Lula ganó en La
Barriada con más del 65% de los votos al
igual que en la mayoría de favelas de la
ciudad como vidigal mareo alemao todo a
pesar de que el estado de Río de Janeiro
es fuertemente bolsonarista al final la
gente pasa hombre y solo los pobres
ayudan a los pobres Y es que las favelas
como rosiña son un reflejo del perfil de
los votantes del ex mandatario de
izquierdas ya que según la última
encuesta de Data [__] los más pobres
las mujeres los afro y los más jóvenes
se decantan por el líder del partido los
trabajadores estamos pagando nueve
dólares por un kilo de carne con tres
piezas y van a votar por bolsonaru en
serio es Lula l bolsonaro tiene apoyos
en las favelas pero su popularidad ha
bajado por su gestión de la pandemia y
el repunte del hambre factores que
empujaron a personas como Antonio dos
Santos peluquero de rosina ha decantarse
por Lula en estas elecciones a pesar de
haber votado por bolsonaro en el 2018
el tipo parecía que se tomaba la
pandemia en broma
niños muriendo mujeres perdiendo a sus
maridos hombres perdiendo a sus esposas
y a él no le importaba
ahí durante su campaña Lula ha prometido
a los pobres como la mayoría de la
población de rosina que alejará el
hambre de sus vidas y a propósito de
estas elecciones los invitamos a que se
conecten mañana desde las 18 horas de
Bogotá quito y Lima con nuestro especial
de noticias con motivo de este debate
los candidatos a la presidencia de
Brasil Luis Ignacio lulada Silva y el
presidente Yair bolsonar
cambiamos de tema vamos a Ecuador donde
concluyó este viernes el diálogo entre
el gobierno del país y los movimientos
de los pueblos originarios esos diálogos
son el resultado del paro de 18 días del
pasado mes de junio que se acabó cuando
el gobierno de Guillermo lasso había
acordado la reducción de 5 centavos más
al precio del galón de la gasolina para
ampliar este tema nos conectamos en
Quito con Augusto Barrera les experto
movimientos indígenas Ecuatorianos y
director del centro para la
transferencia de conocimiento e
Innovación social de la pontificia
Universidad Católica de Ecuador señor
Barrera Bienvenido a Francia 24
cuéntenos que logró acordarse en esas
mesas de diálogo que duraron 90 días y
qué sería según usted lo que se puede
destacar
Buenas noches Muchas gracias por
invitación Andrés efectivamente el día
de ayer terminaron los 90 días que el
gobierno y las organizaciones habían
establecido como un plazo para el
proceso de diálogo después de la
movilización que ocurrió en junio se
definió un proceso que fue mediado por
la conferencia episcopal ecuatoriana por
la iglesia y por tres universidades y se
instalaron 10 mesas de trabajo para
poder desarrollar efectivamente el
proceso de discusión y de diálogo quizás
vale la pena enfatizar que esto deriva
de un documento que es un acta de paz no
no estamos hablando necesariamente de un
proceso con una sola demanda las 10
mesas de diálogo contemplan cosas tan
complejas Digamos como la focalización
del Social los combustibles el tema de
educación superior el tema de salud el
tema de derechos colectivos temas de
seguridad temas de acceso a justicia
etcétera es más parecido digamos a un
plan de gobierno que a una demanda
específica Cuál es el balance de ayer el
balance de ayer se materializa se
refleja en un conjunto importante de
acuerdo sin duda y aproximadamente 210
acuerdos que están establecidos y
marcados pero también se registra un
conjunto importante de desacuerdos de
aspectos con los cuales no se produjo
efectivamente un consenso y que quedan
en este momento abiertos Entonces vamos
a decir así es un balance parcial
efectivamente hay un conjunto de
acuerdos pero quedan otros elementos que
todavía no tienen digamos el consenso de
las partes y que tiene que seguir siendo
procesados ahora cuáles son esos
desacuerdos a los que usted se refiere
mire podríamos digamos clasificar un
poquito en dos grandes grupos no
aquellos elementos que tienen que ver
más con derechos colectivos y en algunos
casos medidas de orden social por
ejemplo derechos colectivos de pueblos y
nacionalidades el tema de salud indígena
el tema de Educación indígena y mejor
acceso eso en general han tenido una
mayor viabilidad los que tienen
dificultades son los que están más
referidos a lo que podríamos llamar como
el modelo productivo de desarrollo
general hay desacuerdo por ejemplo en
cómo tratar el tema del subsidio a los
combustibles Cuál es el mecanismo que
permitiría efectivamente enfrentar esto
hay un desacuerdo importantísimo en
relación al enfoque extractivista o no
del modelo de desarrollo que tiene que
ver con No solamente la consulta libre
que deben tener los pueblos para
permitir en esos territorios la
extracción sino respecto del propio
modelo hay algunos desacuerdos por
ejemplo en relación al enfoque que puede
tener en aspectos como la
flexibilización laboral Entonces no son
como ustedes acaban de ver digamos temas
menores y por eso podríamos decir que
hay un balance de alguna manera un claro
oscuro No es cierto en el resultado que
se tiene de este proceso Mira Augusto
Barrera experto en movimientos indígenas
Ecuatorianos Gracias por acompañarnos en
este análisis cambiamos de tema vamos
Haití que recibió este sábado ayuda
proveniente de Estados Unidos y Canadá
para combatir la ola de inseguridad que
azota al país se trata de vehículos
tácticos y blindados además de otros
suministros entregados a la Policía
Nacional con los que reforzarán su lucha
contra las bandas criminales que están
bloqueando el flujo de asistencia
humanitaria que se necesita de manera
crítica de acuerdo con cifras de la ONU
más de 4 millones de personas enfrentan
inseguridad alimentaria aguda
por segunda noche consecutiva la capital
de túnez vivió protestas que derivaron
en enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
uniformados autos en llamas se vieron en
las calles mientras decenas de civiles
lanzaban piedras a los uniformados que
respondieron con gas lacrimógeno esta
tarde dos grupos de oposición rivales
organizaron una de las mayores
movilizaciones contra el presidente
caixayet los manifestantes denunciaban
las acciones para mantenerse en el poder
y su manejo económico el país atraviesa
una escasez de combustible y alimentos
Mientras que el mandatario asegura que
se trata de actos que buscan
desestabilizar su gobierno Manuela Cano
con los detalles
muchas voces unidas en un mismo pedido
afuera caixayet
miles se reunieron en la capital de
túnez para mostrar su descontento con el
actual mandatario
también esta manifestación es para
expresar una vez más nuestro rechazo a
las medidas políticas anunciadas por
caixayet y las próximas elecciones que
solo fortalecerán la tiranía y la
dictadura en el país
uno de los mayores días de protesta que
denunciaba la toma del poder por parte
de sayet el año pasado que pasó a
gobernar por decreto después del cierre
del parlamento y tiempo después aumentó
sus poderes con la instauración de una
nueva constitución
para muchos se trata de un retroceso en
la lucha hacia la democracia que
encontró su punto más álgido en 2011
cuando después de enormes protestas se
derrocó al régimen autocrático de cine
y desencadenó la denominada como
Primavera
el pueblo tunecino que luchó durante 50
años por la democracia no permitirá que
el golpe de estado sea asiento en este
país y ha visto el alcance de la mala
gestión la incompetencia y el fracaso
[Aplausos]
el descontento en túnez va en aumento la
falta de productos básicos como el
aceite vegetal el azúcar y el arroz y el
aumento del costo del agua ha
desencadenado en un gran malestar
colectivo
voy a defender a mi país y a defender
nuestros derechos tú necesitas sangrando
el hambre y la pobreza ya no tenemos
nada en túnez
mientras la oposición al gobierno parece
estar más unida que nunca sayet denuncia
que intentos dentro del país de socavar
la independencia
en Rusia un tiroteo en un campamento de
entrenamiento militar dejó al menos 11
personas muertas y otras 15 heridas el
hecho se produjo en la región de
belcorot fronteriza con Ucrania según el
Ministerio de defensa ruso dos hombres
armados pertenecientes A una ex
República soviética no identificada
dispararon contra soldados que se habían
ofrecido como voluntarios para ser
enviados a la guerra estoy medio del
reclutamiento ordenado por el presidente
Vladimir Putin desde Moscú nuestro
corresponsal Javier colas con los
detalles
11 soldados rusos han muerto y 15 han
resultado heridos después de que dos
personas abriesen fuego contra un grupo
de voluntarios que se preparaban para
marchar al frente a luchar contra
Ucrania ha ocurrido en la región rusa de
velogros que limita precisamente con
Ucrania al en un campo de tiro mientras
se estaban llevando a cabo pruebas
precisamente para entrenar a los
soldados para disparar las dos personas
que han abierto fuego han sido abatidas
prácticamente a continuación no se sabe
estas horas sus nacionalidad pero sí se
ha dicho que son ciudadanos de una ex
República soviética están siendo unos
días agitados en bergoroth hoy mismo
también ha sido atacado un depósito de
combustible en esa región limítrofes
repetimos con Ucrania aparece que ha
sido un ataque ucraniano Aunque a estas
horas kiev no ha reivindicado ninguna de
las dos acciones
hasta que es informativo en francés 24
Gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos a
que continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]